spider-man does what a spider can he's
got comics cartoons video games movies
hell he even invented the power rangers
but just who is spider-man so peter
parker is your average everyday teen who
lives with his aunt and uncle and has a
burning passion for school science and
wheat cakes
yeah wheat cakes however his love of
breakfast foods and chemistry didn't
exactly translate well for him around
his peers and peter found himself the
target of constant bullying and
alienation this led to peter being a bit
of a loner and results in him attending
an atomic science exhibit by himself and
coincidentally being bitten by a
radioactive spider
oh god this can't be osha compliant this
spider bite irradiated peter's blood and
gave him a variety of spider-themed
superpowers this includes the
proportionate strength and agility of a
spider wall crawling and his trademark
spider sense which warns him of nearby
threats is this what 5g feels like so
the clear head peter does what any teen
with superpowers would do he goes to the
sunday night superslam
from there peter jump starts his career
in show business and makes himself a
costume and a pair of web shooters
taking on the stage name spider-man life
is looking good for peter until one day
after an appearance on dr phil peter
witnesses a man running from the police
and rather than being a narc he lets the
guy get away a couple days later tragedy
strikes as peter's uncle ben is murdered
during a botched robbery
enraged peter dons the spider-man suit
to enact his own brand of vigilante
justice but after tracking down the perp
he realizes
this is the fugitive i like get away
from the police
well well
if it isn't the consequences of my own
actions
from here peter vows to use the powers
he received to help others living by the
mantra with responsibility great
power comes great
wait i think i got that back so as you
can tell peter is kind of a
and this definitely isn't the last time
he'd screw the pooch to list a few
examples breaking and entering into the
base of the fantastic four to look for a
job harassing the unstable owner of a
right-wing news outlet to the point of
having him put out a literal hit on
spider-man pissing off enough super
villains to have them unionize
repeatedly getting his aunt may
kidnapped by sheer coincidence
accidentally killing wolverine's
girlfriend becoming a man spider
going to florida
it's honestly charming how bad
spider-man is at his job but somehow
through sheer force of will he manages
to make his way into college and meets
the love of his life gwen stacy who then
dies it's too late spider-man but don't
worry your webbing didn't kill her
i'm sure she died from the shark far
before
you didn't kill her
so there's no need oh god gwen i'll
never love a woman like i loved you
you and i were going to live the rest of
our lives together and it was going oh
god this is so awkward
so spidey was having a bit of a rough
patch between his girlfriend dying and
his roommate harry osborne doing some
real hard drugs but then mary jane
swoops in she and peter get married and
everything overall is pretty swell for a
while he gets possessed by a black alien
briefly you can't escape me i'll chase
you to the ends of the earth
oh and then venom shows up holy [ __ ] is
that tom hardy
then there was the clone saga we're not
talking about the clone saga do not ask
me to talk about the clone saga but
after that pete goes about his business
being the friendly neighborhood
spider-man dealing with villains around
new york or occasionally space new york
but then the government steps in and
starts telling superheroes they can't be
going around being superheroes anymore
because some dumb kids blew up half of
connecticut filming a reality tv show
iron man supports this full force and as
a publicity stunt has spider-man reveal
his identity on national television he
also gives him the sickest suit i've
ever seen look at it it's so [ __ ]
cool but then peter turns on iron man
because it turns out that letting your
secret identity out to the world is
kind of a bad idea how dare you make me
face the consequences of my actions pete
at this point is on the run as a
fugitive and on the run from the various
villains of new york eventually they
catch up to him and aunt may ends up
getting shot god dammit the consequences
of my actions pete is at rock bottom
nearly every single support structure in
his life has crumbled there's nowhere
for him to run or hide but at least he
still has mary jane and then satan shows
up oh come on mephisto basically tells
peter that editorial isn't too happy
with peter still being married to mary
jane and if peter wants everything to go
back to normal he has to give mephisto
his marriage
yeah
comic books are stupid so peter and mj
agree and with a little magic tom
foolery from doctor strange everyone
forgets that peter parker is spider-man
after that things finally start looking
up for peter yeah he's not married
anymore but he finally gets to go back
to his old life he manages to land a
nice job he's actually making money all
in all everything is going pretty well
and then he gets body swapped with doc
awk and dies
this is [ __ ]
sounds like a skill issue from there
duck parades around as the superior
spider-man and has a pretty heartwarming
face turn but then readers wanted peter
back so doc gives the body back to peter
who wasn't actually dead because part of
his mind was backed up in the
subconscious of doc ock because yeah
sure why not so peter's back now and
apparently while he was away duncan
started a multi-billion dollar
enterprise so peter fumbles his way
through the wondrous world of capitalism
he then shortly bankrupts the entire
company and then loses the trademark to
spider-man how do you even do that
peter for all intents and purposes is a
professional bag fumbler
but that's honestly the central theme of
spider-man
he's a very
human character despite being a hero and
having wondrous abilities he [ __ ] up
all the time he constantly has to pick
up after his own messes he makes the
wrong decisions
just as much as he makes the right ones
but he never gives up and he always
pushes to do the right thing
so yeah that's spider-man
[Music]
you can rewrite dna on the fly
and you're using it to turn people into
dinosaurs
but with tech like that you could cure
cancer but i don't want to cure cancer i
want to turn people into dinosaurs